the family of the late actor Bill Paxton
is suing a hospital and surgeon who
operated on him alleging wrongful death
they claim a quote improper medical
procedure had caused his death last year
Paxton was just 61 years old he starred
and hit movies like Apollo 13 and
twister
Latimer duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is following this story
Vlad good morning it was so sudden when
we heard of his death really was sudden
and the family was shocked good morning
bill paxton had surgery for a heart
condition called aortic aneurysm a year
ago today he died 11 days later from a
stroke now his family is alleging
wrongful death negligence and battery
against the surgeon and the hospital are
you ready to go back to Titanic from
iconic blockbuster movies to an
acclaimed television series hey neighbor
Happy Easter
Bill Paxton was one of Hollywood's most
popular stars his untimely death in 2017
shocked the industry and is something
his family now believes could have been
prevented in a lawsuit filed on Friday
Paxson's family alleges the surgeon who
operated on Paxton dr. Ali Wayne Assad
lacked experience to perform a high-risk
an unconventional surgical approach to
repair the actors heart they also
claimed quaintness odd and the Los
Angeles Hospital where the procedure was
performed cedars-sinai Medical Center
concealed information relating to the
risks of surgery this case it reads well
but it's not backed up with anything
from a medical standpoint or attorneys
David DiPietro specializes in medical
malpractice he says both sides will rely
heavily upon expert opinion if the case
moves to trial medical malpractice cases
are all battle of the experts and it's
it can the expert explained it to a jury
that has no medical knowledge as to why
there was a deviation in the standard of
care cedars-sinai Medical Center says
that while privacy laws prevent us from
commenting about patient care nothing is
more important than the health and
safety of our patients dr. Peter
Anastasio that is a less common way of
doing it but at the same time one that
is certainly within the realm of safety
while he says the alleged procedure
performed on Paxton is high-risk it's
not unconventional Paxson's family says
dr. coin azad was not in the hospital
when Paxton began suffering from
complications after the surgery the
PacSun family attorneys say Quinn Azad
left his position at cedars-sinai
shortly after the actor's death dr.
Quinn Azad has not responded to our
request for comment okay thank you